- My next guest is a very
funny man whom you've seen
in New Girl and The Neighborhood.
He's also the father of
two children, a credit
that inspired him to create DADZ.
It's the first dad-focused
parenting and baby goods company.
Let's say hi to the truly
talented Max Greenfield.
What's up, Max!
- Hey!
- I love your quarantine stache.
- It's a whole thing.
(laughs)
- I love it, did you try the full beard
or you just went for Tom Selleck?
- I went beard at first
and then they were like,
"Don't touch your face."
And (laughs) then I was itching
the beard and I was like,
"I gotta shave this off
so I don't get sick."
And then I was like, "Well
I shouldn't shave it all."
And then, now I just have a mustache.
- It's awesome, look
CHiPs is gonna be calling.
I'm into it.
Well your kids are 10 and four now,
so how has it been locked inside with them
for the last four months?
- We've really gotten to know each other.
(laughs)
- Probably about as good as mine.
I love how honest you are.
And it's crazy though, right?
I feel like, here's the thing,
I started therapy up again
in quarantine because I
was like, "I need someone
"to talk to outside of this
house and I will pay them."
So I literally was telling
my therapist, like,
"I feel like it's almost
like two different humans
in one body."
It'll be so great and then all the sudden
it's just like demons
are just coming out at me
and I don't know what is happening.
- Yeah, I don't know.
Because my daughter's
10 and my son is four
and there's this thing, that's
a pretty significant age gap,
so there's not a lot
of things or activities
- Oh, to do together.
- to do together.
- Yeah.
- So a lot
of it is like keeping one at bay,
and then really focusing on one,
and then going back and forth,
- Yeah.
- and then you're sort of
caught off guard when you're with one
and it's going really well,
like the homeschooling
with my daughter, there
are days, most days,
I think it goes really well
and I'm like "Ooh, we're in a good zone.
"She's reading and we're doing this."
And then I'll go to my son
and be like "All right, you're
good, you're doing this."
I go over to my son and
my son's like (groans),
and I go "No, we just had a good vibe.
"Why are you gonna ruin
the vibe over here?"
- All right, well everybody
at home, Max homeschooled
his daughter through
the end of fourth grade.
No easy task.
He recorded some of those lessons
and made a little mash up.
Can we play that?
Because it's awesome.
- So how do you find
the area of the square?
- So basically.
- Okay, so how do you find the perimeter?
- How do you find the perimeter
of an irregular shape?
- So basically.
- Who fought the French-Indian War?
- So basically the Indians.
♪ Ain't trying to be cool like you ♪
♪ Wobblin' around in
your high heel shoes ♪
♪ I'm clumsy ♪
- In a book, what's the glossary?
- So basically, it's like the dictionary
but like much smaller.
Okay.
Hi.
Whoa!
- How would you describe this hairstyle?
- So basically, it's like
a dog because I love dogs.
(laughs)
- Okay, so basically she got it,
and you just didn't understand, I guess.
So basically, (laughs) it was awesome.
Like does she always
start sentences like that?
- Yeah, she does and then we did the video
and it was really funny
and people have responded
how funny they thought it was,
and I think she thought "Oh,
I should like up the amount
"of times that I'm saying so basically."
It sort of reaffirmed
and gave her confidence
in that phrase, and I,
since, had to be like "Hey,
"so we don't wanna start
every sentence with that."
- Yeah, well see maybe a few.
(laughs)
- Yeah, and I don't wanna discourage her
and make her feel bad about it,
- Yeah.
- but there was a gentle sort
of like "Let's find a different end
"to when we're just talking
about, I don't know, anything."
- Yeah, well on a serious note,
what did you learn from
teaching fourth grade
for a couple of months?
- Oh my god, patience.
Really.
(laughs)
It was a real exercise in patience.
- Do you ever find
yourself doing the homework
and going, "I don't know how to do this
"and I'm a grown woman."
- So much of it.
So much of it, I can't even tell you.
There was like, I got to a point where,
because the beginning was
just completely overwhelming,
and then you get into a groove
and you sort of start realizing.
Okay, so there's this math assignment.
They're like tessellations.
I've never even heard about tessellations,
so I told Lily that she's
probably never gonna hear
of one, either--
- Probably never gonna use this.
- No one will use this.
(laughs)
But then some
of the other stuff, like the English
and storytelling and some
of the writing assignments,
we really focused on
and I think we did a good job.
There were some real wins in this.
- And you gotta celebrate those.
- Yeah.
- Well what about your son?
Did he learn anything?
Did you do any Zoom stuff
with him?
- No.
(laughs)
- You just can focus on the one.
- He's four and a half.
They'll be some significant damage to him
and we have time to make that up.
Whereas Lily's 10 and she's
really on the precipice
of some important stuff
and if she gets to,
she can get left behind right now,
and we're trying to avoid that.
So my son, we'll figure him out.
- Well, speaking of being
a dad though, tell me
about this new company you founded, DADZ.
- Yeah, we're really excited about it.
Honestly, I don't know that I'm
ever gonna be doing anything
other than hanging out with these kids,
and trying to take care of them,
so we decided to start
a business out of it.
But it really started
a communication, a lot
of this has started a communication
between me and a lot of other dads,
and just reaching out with support
and laughter, and sharing
a lot of these moments,
and I talked to these guys
who had started this, I
had this idea for DADZ
and I jumped right in.
I loved what they were about.
Supporting dads and
supporting this community,
and just actively trying
to get dads more involved,
and really just having a product line
for dads that supports one another and--
- It's crazy that it hasn't
really happened before.
- I know, and that's what
we have been talking about,
and that's what we're trying to do,
and we have a charitable
aspect to our company
and a lot of our proceeds will go
to a revolving door of
different father charities.
The one we're working with right now
is called Fathers Incorporated
that's based in Atlanta,
and this is just a real positive company,
and I'm so excited to be involved.
- That's so cool.
It's a great, innovative idea.
I wanna show the photo though
from your press release for DADZ
because it's so awesome.
- Yeah.
(laughs)
- And such a great example
of what really happens.
I love that most people, you know,
they make their Instagrams
like a fake life,
like a fake version of their life.
Yours is like real.
(laughs) And that's what's so awesome,
because are they really,
is this a real reaction?
Is he really crying?
- Yeah, this is what happens if I try
to get everyone in the picture.
- Well man, thank you
so much for joining us.
You are hysterical.
I love you.
Every time you come here,
everybody, we were all talking
about it before you logged in.
- Oh, you're the best.
I love coming on.
This has been so great.
- Yes.
- Thanks for having me.
- And good luck to your family
and all of our families.
We're all stuck at home and
this has been really hard
and, relatively speaking, for
everyone in their own world
so thank you so much for joining us
and Max thanks so much.
Tell your kiddos thank you
because that made me laugh so hard.
Well, DADZ is rolling out
new products all the time.
Check out their website
for more info, everybody.